the Joe Rogan experience one of the
things that I really enjoyed about your
book was when you explain to people that
everyone who practices a religion is an
atheist you're just an atheist in
regards to Zeus or Apollo 999 other gods
yes and that that's a home run
yeah this Ark yes because just go one
God further yes yeah but that it really
is a home run because this is this
concept of you know I me and my friends
jokingly what would always say praise
Odin when anything would happen it was
that pretty good cool yes we say praise
Odin and I started doing it online and
people really got into saying praise
Odin about certain things rather like
that yes some people get mad at me
they actually got mad that I was you're
mocking Christianity by saying pretty
you are
why not really I was just having fun yes
I was having fun because I owed encima
we're cool God you know I was it's a old
school god I mean it's the god of the
Vikings Douglas Adams wrote a lovely
book called the long dark teatime of the
soul which had in which the Norse gods
support a vision Odin in that in that
book has got old and senile and he he's
just lies in bed all the time and asking
for clean sheets every day and Thor is
out there doing mischief with his great
hammer and at one point
Odin sees gets Thor super glued to the
floor and thinks it's a wonderful story
the vast number of different religions
the I mean the incredible number I mean
how many how many actual religions are
there thousands thousands yes I said I
forget how many thousand good and many
of them share similar belief systems and
it's really interesting when you see how
they're put like you know the Noah's Ark
story is very similar to the Epic of
Gilgamesh and there's so many that you
see like oh they probably told this to
someone else and these people moved in
coast
yeah it's traveled on and it's it's just
amazing that that concept is alien to
people when I was a boy I was raised
Catholic
and I had an aunt who was Jewish and my
uncle married my aunt and he had to
convert to Judaism
and it was like a big deal in the family
everybody would talk about it and it's
there was no anger everybody loved my
aunt she's great lady but it was just
strange that he was converting to the
size of other religion I remember I was
five years old when this was going on
and it was like wait wait what do you
mean another religion yes what's going
on yes and they're like oh she's Jewish
I go what what does that mean what do
you mean she's Jewish yes and they had
explained it to me yeah okay but she
believes in God like yeah that they
believe in God okay so why is it a
different thing well they believe Jesus
was a different kind of a thing it was
they don't they don't necessarily
believe use the guy that we think he was
but if it's being Hindu they'd have had
to explain to you they believe in
hundreds of god Vishnu and yes
yes yeah and then we'd have to go way
back yeah it's just when you first hear
that I mean that was put probably put
the first seeds of doubt in my head when
I was a young boy when I was like with
this more than one like I'll never
forget that moment cuz we're all sitting
around the dinner table and I was just a
little kid and everything what do you
mean there's another one I think that's
a very powerful way of getting to
children is to just simply tell them
that yes telling them nothing but facts
you're not indoctrinated right he was
telling them there are lots of different
religions and Hindus believe in hundreds
of gods and Jews would even one God and
Muslims believe in one God and they
don't believe in Jesus and and just lay
out all the different religions that
would be a very good educational
exercise has there ever been a
civilization that existed without a
belief in a higher power I don't think
there has No
of course there are plenty of
individuals who educate that don't
believe in a higher power but I think
probably true to say that every every I
mean anthropologist might might deny
them and there might be some tribe that
doesn't but I suspect they will do well
there's been some tribes that worshiped
animals and particularly oh yeah they
survived off of yes yeah yeah and and
and and river gods and thunder gods and
and moon gods and Sun gods and fire gods
and things yes
[Applause]